the next guest is home kellehara thank
you comb for waiting for so long look at
you
like a boss there well I'm actually uh
still at my day job which is
um in the background they're a big law
Institute for Consciousness studies but
um yeah I have to throw a projection
behind you in 20 minutes or so but uh I
just wanted to come on to
congratulate you for so many different
really good shows during the year
um it's it's been a really
um I think good year
and may 2023 be even better
thank you thank you so just so you know
Sam here who's the jockey more than just
that but today serving is the is the
is the mediator of all of this his
favorite episode on toe from 2022 was
yours
Sam that's all right thank you
yeah it's very gratifying thank you for
coming out Chris do you have any
questions for Coleman have you met each
other
we we almost did comb I I just actually
tonight released a episode one I don't
know if it was a few weeks back uh in
November uh Carl Crusher
and Chris Bartel we came to your office
but we didn't want to come in with too
many people you know so I I waited
outside actually but uh they came in
just asked yeah to ask about Mount
Wilson Ranch we are on our way up to up
to Mount Wilson Ranch
uh basically because Bigelow owned it as
well and had Jacque Valley in Ingo Swann
and all the guys up there um so
basically looking at it Mount Wilson
Ranch uh for those of you who don't know
um is
um up in uh near Pioche in Nevada about
a hundred and something miles north of
Las Vegas but uh part of our research
during the needs operation at the very
beginning of the news Operation was to
kind of split our time between
Skinwalker Ranch and also the Mount
Wilson Ranch and I can tell you that we
did not see a lot of uh unusual activity
up there but they were the best
absolutely best uh views of the Milky
Way galaxy I have ever seen in my life I
mean it's 8 000 feet up there and
there's really not a lot of ambient
light in the in the the near environment
and it was spectacular so we spent many
many cold nights out there especially
especially during the winter on Mount
Wilson Ranch and
um you know we had night vision
equipment which made stargazing even
more spectacular
um so it was it was a very enjoyable
time I'm
um obviously Chris Bartel and uh and his
uh his research brand were were in my or
in my building there a few weeks ago so
I'm sorry I didn't meet you
yeah it would have been next that's
great to hear actually well well
obviously we're looking for Paranormal
Activity there as well but we're also
setting up uh camera systems
yeah hundreds of acres and so we can uh
set up you know kind of a at least three
the plan is at least three camera
systems you know so we can triangulate
so separated by some distance so
hopefully we'll we'll at least we'll
have eyes upward I I don't know at this
stage what the living space is
um on the on the uh Mount Wilson range
but when I when we were up there when
niz was up there we had a
um a series of sort of small
um small cottage like buildings one of
which was reputedly haunted by this uh
Native American person
um
yes several of us slept in that
particular room but none of us saw
anything
um it was
um
but
I I have fond memories of Mount Wilson
okay yeah excellent
interesting yeah it's a six Show episode
or miniseries so I'll be releasing it
out and then in the spring we plan to go
back and put up uh extra cameras so it'd
be nice yeah maybe I can interview you
if I'm coming through and I'll put it in
a vlog yeah yeah absolutely I I uh I'd
really enjoy that
um I'd also uh like to get maybe at the
end of this
um a link to your to your uh release
yeah so it's Chris Leto or the Leto
files and I'll send that to you
personally calm so don't worry you don't
need to write it down okay great and
also I will put it on screen for people
who are interested and comb what what is
it that you're working on in 2022 that
we can promote right now so that I can
put a link on the screen for people who
are interested in following
well the
um
as you as you know from the last
interview we did with myself and George
with you uh we released a book just uh
about just about a year ago now just
slightly over a year ago called Skin
markers at the Pentagon that really was
um we thought it was the sort of
um correcting the record in quote
unquote on the uh the program with the
defense intelligence agency which was
the boots on the ground UFO
investigative program
um there is an audio version of that
book coming out in January
um which we're pretty happy with but
um we think that the the overall program
was the sort of the Genesis of a lot of
the activity that is uh that is ongoing
now because there's a direct linear
relationship between the OSAP program
and then the much smaller atip program
but even then leading into the the um
the UAP task force the the there was a
couple of generations of the UAP task
force that uh that were very much tied
in terms of lineage to the OSAP program
the um Advanced Aerospace Weapons
Systems application program which
um we ran from Las Vegas I was the
project manager in Las Vegas and then a
a ballistic missile physicist called
James T lakowski was the program manager
in in Washington so jointly we ran that
program
um over about a 27-month period and
during that time
it was mostly a boots on the ground
field investigative effort
um so we ended up hiring about 50
different people in a very short period
of time which you know has its pluses
and minuses
um and we um we we did have
investigators
um around the United States and also we
deployed investigators to Brazil at one
stage in order to
um really sort of come to grips with the
the UFO phenomenon we were mostly
interested in
um both sensor sensor driven data as
well as effects on people uh so we we
kind of ran two parallel programs one
was uh try to capture uh sensor data and
the other was trying to capture
um effects on people and we had two MD
phds on staff that did a lot of that
um
medical injury investigation so
um it was very much a sort of a Hands-On
boots on the ground effort and all of
the writing in terms of reports and all
of that had to be done after all of the
research was conducted so
um it was a lot of fun
um
but you know hopefully in 2023 there
will be some kind of light at the end of
the tunnel regarding
um
you know right regarding a new program
uh although you know as time goes on
um
I I must say I'm not as optimistic as I
was you know because I'm frequently
disappointed
every time I think the two 800 pound
gorillas in the room are the
ousdi and S I mean back back in the in
the day when we were investigating UFOs
uh with the defense intelligence agency
um that that particular organization the
Pentagon was plain old usdi under
secretary of defense for intelligence
but now it's the office of under
secretary for defense intelligence and
security
um we found that particular organization
less than
um Cooperative in sort of helping out on
the on the um you know on the the
bureaucratic red tape uh front the
second 800 pound gorilla in the room is
the United States Air Force which has
been notably reticent in terms of of
bringing forth
um additional data although you know
I've heard that there are there are you
know
there's a better level of cooperation
than there was sort of a year ago uh but
you know for example Frank Kendall the
the secretary of the Air Force recently
came out with a sort of a series of
statements that was not exactly positive
um they're basically saying that that
they the USAF did not see any there
there so therefore they're going to wait
for any evidence before putting any
muscle behind that and I I think there
are the two main organizations that have
uh their stakeholders in this whole
process in ushering this new office
um into some kind of productivity
so I'm I guess I'm I'm less
um less optimistic than I was nine
months ago because I think Congress can
do a lot and you know the recent passage
of the National Defense authorization
act
um which still needs uh authorization
bills to to pass uh but the recent
passage of the ndaa I think with the
with the appropriate language for
whistleblowers to come forth and all of
that I think that's a wait and see
because realistically a lot of the
intelligence agencies the defense
intelligence agency the Central
Intelligence Agency have their own ways
of doing this and whether or not they're
actually going to cooperate and sort of
lie down for a series of sort of
amnesties
um is is an open question I personally
think it's going to be a very slow
process
so John Ramirez on Martin Willis's
podcast which by the way as a plug
Martin Willis has a podcast called UFO
or sorry called The Martin Willis live
show maybe the live UFO show I'm I'm
sure I'm uncertain about the specific
name regardless there was a prediction
made
fairly adamantly by John Ramirez about
2027 being a day or sorry being a year
that's important for the UFO phenomenon
in particular that UFOs May land or
touch down then so comb have you heard
anything of about this what do you make
of it
I've seen that scuttlebutt but I I have
not seen anything to substantiate it I
don't I haven't seen anybody who I would
sort of
um
class as a as an Insider's quote-unquote
uh come out with that I I've seen the
scuttlebutt but I honestly don't know
so what are you most grateful for man
from all this year all of this year 2022
well I I think actually 2022 was uh was
a banner year for sort of the unfolding
of uh of this program and uh not only
the the program but the level of
interest in the public
so
um and also i i s the reason I'm very
optimistic uh from what has happened in
2022 is that I think that there's more
and more uh people in the the so-called
Consciousness field
um that are beginning to take an
interest in the
um in the UFO field and the on this and
this idea that there's cross correlation
between the UFO field and uh paranormal
activity for example and Consciousness
um with people like Jeffrey [ __ ] uh
don Donald Hoffman Edward Kelly and
um you know there's a husband who
commented on UFOs as far as you know
um I'm Jeffrey kreifel certainly has
um Ed Kelly no but but
um I think Donald Huffman has been asked
uh that question numerous earlier he was
on
I'll ask him next time yeah yeah I mean
it would be really interesting because I
mean he's pushing the boundaries a lot
in terms of this whole
um this new paradigm in Consciousness
that is you know the Consciousness is
not necessarily the result of
biochemical trafficking in the in the
brain and that you know there's a lot
more to the story than than that and um
I see that as
um and people like Jeffrey [ __ ] from
Rice University who is kind of really
getting into a much higher profile with
uh linking in Consciousness and UFOs I
see that as very positive because
ultimately you know
um you can deploy sensors in the field
and we have uh project has to land in
Norway is a very good example of that of
having
um having
sensors for 40 years but you know the
effects of UFOs on people the effects of
UFOs on people's perception and even on
their worldview
um is something that really should be uh
run in parallel to the actual Gathering
of the physics and the engineering data
I I think there's room for both in this
whole field and I I would say there's
room for optimism certainly on on from
my perspective there's room for optimism
well calm I know that you got to get
going so do you have any
if you have a last question Chris to
post a comb then please do so if not
then Como give you an outro uh do you
have any insights common to who could
possibly be called if there are public
hearings or who I guess who would you be
most most excited to see
you know call to a public hearing
um that's a that's a pretty good
question
um
I I can tell you that a lot of the
people that were involved in the ASAP
program
um were very are where and are very much
um interested in this whole uh Arena
people like Hal putoff and Eric Davis
who were intimately involved in the ASAP
program
um I would not be in the least surprised
to see people like that
um
being asked to testify plus there's a
lot of different my information at least
is that there's a lot of people who are
willing to come forward uh whatever
um what effect that has I I really I
really don't know I I think the office
of the under secondary Professor
intelligence
um it's kind of like a wait and see
um situation
um but you know I I think
um
you know I think time will tell 2023
will will be an interesting year
[Music]
comb thank you so much the book is
called Skin Walkers at the Pentagon and
the link will be in the description
thank you thank you for for spending the
end of the the end of your year with me
well I I really appreciate what you're
doing Kurt and uh I wish uh both of you
actually a and uh whoever's listening
um a great New Year hopefully
um the odd bottle of Guinness will be
cracked and you know so
yes I'm from Trinidad ah nice this is
from this is apparently inFAMOUS or
famous among trinidadians this paradrex
I don't drink it well I know I do drink
it on the holidays but I'm well I'm
saying so holiday now Kurt yeah yeah
yeah
I I have this I'm not allowed
I have this this strange
it's like right well whatever I'm not
allowed to eat until after I I do the
majority of my work so we'll see we'll
see my wife is coming to pick me up
shortly so comb it's good to see you and
yeah
during the year yes yeah we'll talk next
year so I haven't asked anyone this but
Have you listened to the theories of
everything podcast comb
like I know we've been on yeah Have you
listened to any of the podcasts I know
we've been on you've been on the podcast
but have you yes I've been I I I've
listened to a couple of Donald Hoffman's
um uh podcasts on you know
um as usual they're sort of way I mean
they're they're exceptional really
exceptional I think you know both of you
interact really well
thank you thank you I was going to ask
which one was which one was your
favorite that's yeah I don't know I've
gone back though I don't know if you
remember the uh particular podcast he
did at the very start of covid with you
um it was uh it was March I think I
guess our April 2020. I found that
exceptional too thank you
well me and you we're gonna create
an exceptional podcast together one that
exceeds the March 2020 one with Hoffman
so I look forward to that in 2023
and I look forward to what you produce
and also let your boss know let Bigelow
know that I would love to speak with him
on the podcast
yeah well you know in the background you
can see Bigelow Institute for
Consciousness studies right now we have
we have launched a grants program
um a funding program which is very rare
in this field of what's what's called
Survival Of Consciousness after death
and so we have launched a program that's
worth up to a million dollars
um it's going to be broken into multiple
different grants of a hundred thousand
dollars and fifty thousand dollars but
in terms of the the field it's an
injection of money into this field which
is badly needed uh for research so right
now what that's what I'm doing is is
managing that programming and getting
the launch
um going for that program so I see that
as as something that could have value in
2023
okay great
goodbye and thanks for coming on
all right you just watched a clip from
an eight hour live stream Behemoth
Leviathan podcast from theories of
everything which is a channel where we
explore physics mathematics and
Consciousness what is the Theory of
Everything how do you merge Quantum
field Theory with General relativities
click here or in the description for the
full podcast where there are several
people make appearances all the way from
George Knapp to Jeremy Corbell to Gary
Nolan to Avi lope to John verbaki to
Donald Hoffman to Michael Levin to Ian
mcgilchrist and 40 more all in one eight
hour long podcast links in the
description